JIMMY TRAN: Hi there.
Jimmy here.
HEATHER CROSS: Always good
to have you back, Jimmy.
In today's episode, we're
going to be focusing
on different Cloud Functions.
JIMMY TRAN: When
building apps, developers
rely on various cloud services,
including storage, messaging,
data analytics, and
mobile development.
As developers expand their
use, seamless integration
between these services
can be a challenge.
HEATHER CROSS: Very true.
So today we'll introduce
Google Cloud Functions,
a solution that allows
you to connect services
together and extend their
behavior just by adding code.
We'll also run through a quick
demo of a self-paced lab that
will allow you to
create, deploy, and test
a Cloud Function.
JIMMY TRAN: Cloud Functions,
sounds pretty generic to me.
So what is it really?
Google Cloud Functions
can be summarized
as a serverless compute
solution for creating
event-driven applications.
HEATHER CROSS: So
let's define an event.
An event could be something like
a change to data in a database
or files added to
a storage system.
You can create a response to
that event with a trigger.
A trigger is an
indication that you're
interested in a certain
event or set of events.
Adding a Cloud
Function to the trigger
allows you to respond
to that event.
JIMMY TRAN: Because the
software and infrastructure
are fully managed by Google, you
only need to provide the code.
A function can scale from a few
requests to millions per day
without any work from you.
HEATHER CROSS: Click here
to view a great introduction
by our Product
Manager, Jason Polites,
about building serverless
applications with Google Cloud
Functions.
JIMMY TRAN: So what can you
do with Cloud Functions?
Let's look at some examples
we can all relate to.
HEATHER CROSS: All
right, I've got one.
You know when you
subscribe to a newsletter--
Hogwarts number one fan--
and you magically get an
email delivered to your inbox?
Yep, that's a trigger
for a Cloud Function.
JIMMY TRAN: Developers
can also take advantage
of Cloud Functions to offload
resource-intensive work that
wouldn't be practical to
run on a user's device.
An example could be
to write a function
that upon upload of an
image to a storage bucket
a thumbnail of the image
is created and then saved
in another bucket.
HEATHER CROSS: That's
another great example, Jimmy.
JIMMY TRAN: Thank you.
HEATHER CROSS: And
of course, there
are many opportunities
to integrate
with third-party
services and APIs, too.
JIMMY TRAN: Now to Qwiklabs--
the Cloud Functions lab
is available for use
with the command line, as well
as through the Google Cloud
Platform console.
You can check out the links
to start the Qwiklabs here.
HEATHER CROSS: In
both labs, you will
create a Cloud Function,
deploy and test the function,
and view logs.
JIMMY TRAN: So far
in the lab, we've
created a Cloud Function
based on an HTTP trigger
and deployed it.
Once deployed, you
can test a function,
provide a triggering event,
in this case, a simple "hello
world" message.
You can see the success of the
tested function in the output
field.
You can easily see the
logs for your function.
Well, there we have it.
Thanks for watching
our quick video
on Google Cloud Functions.
HEATHER CROSS:
Don't forget to keep
visiting our on-air
webinar series, Qwicklabs,
and our blogs.
All the links are below.
JIMMY TRAN: You can also learn
more about Cloud Functions
through our on-demand
courses on Coursera.
Thanks for watching
and see you soon.
HEATHER CROSS: Last week we
discussed Google Kubernetes
Engine and how it could easily
scale, deploy, and automate
your application.
Check out the video and
the Qwiklab demo here.